quanto cinematica questa cosa da tutti
ragazzi benvenuti a questo video sono
pavic e oggi siamo sul primo episodio di
how trust ii
non credevo che mai nella vita sarei
riuscito a dire una roba del genere
perché non credevo sarebbe mai uscito al
2 guarda quando giocato auto stu 1 ai
tempi
porca vacca l'hanno fatto outlast 2
contiene scene di violenza sangue i
contenuti di carattere sessuale ma che
peccato pensavo di giocare lockit io e
linguaggio esplicito buon divertimento
buon divertimento bellissima cantiere
violenza sangue contenuti sessuali e
linguaggio esplicito
buon divertimento grazie
lì in lager ma è una giornalista
investigativa che indaga sull'omicidio
di una ragazza incinta morta in
circostanze inspiegabili nella provincia
rurale dell'arizona ovest i panni di
black lager ma suo marito assistente
cameraman documenta tutto non siete
combattenti quindi l'unico modo per
sfuggire agli orrori che vi attendono in
questo luogo remoto e correre
nascondervi
o morire cosa che io so fare benissimo
continua la grazia se conte ma mai la
pace a sorte l'unica roba ragazzi che
voglio dirvi è che sta arrivando una
bella [ __ ] girarla in troverà tutti
ragazzi sull'elicottero e comunque uni
troppo intelligente della mia ragazzi
quindi va bene
porca ma poi così a caso cioè il senza
un motivo
mickey è che presa di casa che blog che
esce fuori qualche la famiglia hard news
[Musica]
e arrivato il giorno ragazzi che bello
vedevo l'ora di cos'è qualcosa come
perché ci si su cristo nostre non era
così la devo ai pensavo di giocare la
demo all'inizio lo stavo dicendo prima
che credevo che i primi minuti di gioco
fossero come la demo quindi fossero
proprio uguali e rever non sono uguali
alla demo ok ciao gesù sono farisei e
questo e al trust ii che figo jessica
jessica sarebbe la regala dico io son
problemini e ricordare i nomi ragazzi
gesti che la ragazza incinta morta
quella per cui siamo stati ad indagare
salve non è lei jessica vero no perché
social matranga così perché c'è gente
nei corridoi in un posto del genere
serve come sono arrivato io qua scusami
c'è un elicottero che sta accadendo
hai un sogno un sogno per forza ok
quindi non è come la debbano giunto pure
dei pezzi questo è un sogno sicuro e
capacità fare i quadri possibile
[Applauso]
questo è il vociare che c'è in classe
alla mattina quando sono la campanella
uguale
i porti in fascia nella vita lo prese
però non così c'è nel senso
non si sa quando c'è le tue cose zia non
ti ferma nessuno
porca vacca malaga è completamente
diverso alla demo non c'entra nulla
wow c'è l'elicottero che si è schiantato
beh guarda non avevo dubbi
tocca al tasso fisso ripetutamente ok
qual è quella era jessica chi era quella
qualche culo che la videocamera si è
salvata mi chiama ladri ordine su amazon
mica mille euro di videocamera diciamo
che non è proprio una situazione
idilliaca preselezione il tuo obiettivo
in qualsiasi momento
due gli obiettivi li vedi così la che
figata
e va bene andiamo dichiara che proprio
outlet sporca e va poi su un casato vai
così assassin's creed comunque ragazzi
stava già per fare una fine incredibile
proprio così si vede la mia bravura nei
videogiochi perfetto finché raga
veramente assassin's creed e può
accompagnare solo non volevo dirvi larga
che comunque al plasma questo lo sapete
tutti è stato in è stata in assoluto la
serie porca di una [ __ ] sono capaci a
giocare videogiochi faccio questo di
lavoro orca è al suo centro il gradino a
control e che va bene ci siamo è stata
una serie in assoluto più di successo
nel mio canale outros primo quindi
questo deve essere deve valere la pena
di giocarlo tutta la vita gli eventi
importanti devono essere registrati ok
questo è come una youtuber quando
l'indicatore era che lampeggia la
videocamera puntata correttamente
ok hai ore già perché dovrei riprendere
un elicottero che va a fuoco questa la
cosa me ne frega i livelli filmati per
ottenere maggiori informazioni sui
rendimenti obiettivi nostri mari spud
webb è che cazzo dove riproduce ci può
stare fuori ho sentito qualche città lo
vedo anche senza videocamera ed io lo
vedo proprio anche senza però va bene
devo trovavo così come a roma c'è una
cosa ragazzi
what venda ho trovato una benda giusto
perché in un elicottero che sismica
tutto si salva solo la benda ovvio
mariah non vedo niente giangia non vedo
una mazza fantastico produzione serve
ero forse quest'anno poi bloggare zio
questo non c'entra con lynch per dire
che la precedente lavoro un pre nego
l'incidente però ok senta e qua mi si ho
parcheggiato la macchina la zona vede
c'è mica l'esselunga comunque non ho
capito il senso di sta roba ragazzi dove
siamo perché è il caso di un elicottero
dov'è mia moglie e chi fottutamente
jessica jessica dovrebbe essere la
ragazza in città quella che siamo venuti
a trovare in questo posto bellissimo
solo che non ci aspettavamo mai che
fosse così accogliente questo posto ma
che questo riprende qualsiasi cosa
nel mezzo del nulla ma cos'è una pau dio
oddio la casa di leone cane fifone
fantastico permesso la mostra ok braga
quest'area la parte della demo quindi me
la ricordo più o meno camera non che mi
dia meno ansia
porca vacca una volta è brutto perché
doveva best gesù meno male che c'è gesù
in questo gioco sono cougars che
continuavo salve c'è gesù nell'altra
stanza l'ha visto ok questa cosa non mi
ricordò non me la ricordavo questa cosa
bene via via veloce la pensate la
madonna vaffan
non me lo ricordo ragazzi non mi ricordo
la demo ci sono delle cose che non mi
ricordo cos'è al mio zio che brutta cosa
visto che è venuto giù per sbirciare tv
premuto q q ap rosso anche zoomare la
madonna salve amica che gioco regate è
bello 2 while you bello e su triciclo
sono veramente super contento che ci
gente che mi accoglie bene in questo
paese malve vedi che mi accolgono tutti
benissimo
porca [ __ ] pagano dominio non mi
accorgo delle cose ma perché lo
proseguiamo da dove arrivano le urla
permesso non si chiude la porta in
faccia e persone el stivale educatissimi
ok si è aperta questo qua sarebbe una
versione di padre pio ingrassata ma non
so ma zio non è a fuoco questo sta
riprendendo ma non lo sai fare
l'obiettivo persona lo sai fare tu per
non farlo perché dovrei caricare la
batteria forse vedere che è che ne so
ditemelo quindi se non c'è la batteria
la videocamera non mette a fuoco
non capisco il perché ma ok per aprire
le finestre premi tasto sinistro corvi
me lo ricordavo questo non ricordavo che
bello che è pieno di croci in giro
proprio mii
e allegro allegro ora qua il nostro è
proprio ciarla stamani a delle croci e
di gesù cristo il suo gioco c'è qualcuno
in mezzo ai rami si è decisamente
qualcuno in mezzo ai rami portai ma che
cosa amica è questo gioco è sparito
hanno ancora e l'anno scorso non volevo
questa brutta situazione una brutta
solido ma che si gente che ti fissa call
che sono brutti come la fame e tu ti
preoccupi di leggere la scritta che sta
sul muro ma che problemi al cervello ai
zio è buio pesto si vede niente
fantastico gioco della vita poiché non
ho mai capito perché in auto la stan
indifferenza di residenti vol
ci sono i bambini morti per terra non ho
mai capito no non era quella la domanda
non ho mai capito perché nota se non
puoi difenderti mai
c'è poi solo scappare e nascondersi non
venga ok non siamo dei combattenti non
ci difendiamo la porca eva se uno ti
arriva in faccia la spranga in bocca
puoi anche dare cioè assolutamente non
c'è non fa una piega
c'è ancora gente che mi disse no però
non è tanto allegro come zona ma chi è
che sta parlando
chi è che sta parlando lega ci ha
parlato
raga non ho capito
[Musica]
salve sua madre lercia disco è lo sapeva
bene webb ellis geologo marcato noi
pensavo che cammini continuasse a
camminare non camminava manco per il
cazzo benissimo tutta no perché c'era
nella demo qualcosa meno mettete tutta
la demo com'era non è come la demo porca
quando non sappiamo più o meno cosa
aspettarmi di quei corpi no no non è
come laden venne il coro indietro
madonna ci si brutta azienda via via via
via vedere devoto attorno corre anche
più veloce quando c'è la gente che ti
segue mi piace questa cosa vai sempre
volatilizzata oppure ancora in giro ma
perché se ancora in giro se la natura ed
i cieli non si può commerciare massa di
striscia o sta in piedi o striscioni già
via di mezzo
non capisco perché non puoi non puoi
accovacciati normalmente
il problema sono andata raga non ho
capito bene non facciamo domande va bene
così praga che cosa vincerà guardava
dice scusa quindi perché c'è un marte
[Musica]
non lo vedeva bene all'uscita da coveri
uscita da dove cazzo città porca eva ai
ha fatto malissimo tua madre brutta aria
e vabbè migliaia donne incassate le tue
quanto incassato cazzate forti e
ma ha chiesto di portarla al sushi era
pieno ha detto non mi spiace amore
niente sushi la reazione è stata questa
speriamo che non sia di qua cosi
striscioni sotto e devo farlo anche
prima bene vai madonna che brutta cosa
la cosa più brutta di outlast è sempre
stato e quando qualcuno ti rincorre devi
entrare in un pertugio prima che ti
prenda l'ansia che non fa in tempo ad
entrare nel pertugio quella era la
presentazione di tutto out l'ansia di
non riuscire ad arrivare in tempo alla
salvezza è orribile
cioè non vi so spiegare quanto è
orribile è una roba incredibile
veramente visione incredibile sempre
sarà anche auto stoner ha così è cioè un
arsenal
io non odio dio perché devo dire dio ma
poi avete le cose di gesù cristo in giro
perché dovrei studiare dio pagano per
tolosa guarda giocato talmente tanti
horror che il mio a posto di cereali ciò
gli horror io la mattina quindi lo so
che succedono stai tu hai un gli
occhiali ma serve è più o meno la
reazione di quando vediamo la prof di
matematica è dio mi vuole morto
ok me lo segno è sul taccuino ed io mi
vuole morto
me lo ricordo poi metto la sveglia io
non è che uscirei con tanta scioltezza
vista vista le persone che ci sono fuori
però ma tu non ti azzardare manco per il
pene a prendere una pala e difenderti
per carità
sia mai che tu possa salvarti certe
situazioni era un ray mai non ci passo
io di qua non entra ah sì che entra come
ha fatto arretrare e non è tossico che
fisica puoi sentire per essere parenti
localizzare i sogni usando microfono
alla tua videocamera si
[Applauso]
resta la farà dono per l'inter piano
piano
[Applauso]
oh gesù a ruba
marecchia a bra e cira fini pronto
sinistra conto per una strana the ok mi
chiamano male perché sono era un
problema
ovviamente lui limite fatto e finito il
cespuglio cioè che sono uscito a
cespugli come fanno vedermi orbo corpo
proprio lì
[Musica]
non avevamo visto era non abbiamo
incastrato aiuto quel castrato malissimo
tutta nascondigli di cespugli premi
control è sto cazzo contro è andata a
cagare non so io
[Musica]
non c'è la prima con i cespugli lega
però non si passa di qua sempre sono
passato ai dove cassano che per chi è
andato sì quando 6 mar il suo gioco o
l'uccello hanno altre cose albe lei che
canta e niente proviamo a scappare cazzo
mi devo dirlo ma stavo scherzando ma
ringraziando gesù così è successo
me ne frega un cazzo zio non me ne frega
un cazzo non mi vedono ricorrere di
ricorrere una puledra corri corri cioè
nicchia siamo
cos'è che oggi gesù apri apri apri a
palazzo a quel mercato infatti non
capivo come fa parlare a ci mancavano
come stanno parlando di lei
eccola
ha quindi evviva mia moglie che era
importante che sia viva non quello facci
figliola
[Musica]
25 dietro porca vacca che stanno facendo
a mia moglie
ma dei ragazzi concluso il primo
episodio di al trash
so che mi piace quando conclude video
mezzo alle cose
sappiate che si in occasione dell'uscita
di aids non è che uscirà un episodio la
settimana di auto 2 ma uscirà un
episodio ogni due tre giorni c'è questo
perché non voglio farvi aspettare troppo
per il secondo episodio visto che sono
lo guarderà mezzo mondo perché il
videogioco più atteso della vita ed i
ragazzi spero che i primi episodi di
auto vi sia piaciuto a me come gioco c'è
in realtà sembra meglio del primo
ed era difficile credetemi continuano
nei prossimi episodi ragazzi spero che
mi sia piaciuto al solito ragazzi
consenso di precisamente è un bel line
anche i vari social che come le donne
del tiziano sono certi di 16 clicchiamo
il prossimo mito da ragazzi
[Musica]